bonjour à tous les deux merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation alors les
chiffres le montrent en tout cas c'est
du ministère de l'intérieur le mouvement
anti passe
s'affaiblit mais les week end de
mobilisation se poursuive malgré tout à
quoi faut-il s'attendre dans les
prochaines semaines le mouvement va-t-il
perdurer longtemps je vous pose la
question à vous pour commencer gérard
filoche
moi je redis
qu'il faut la vaccination
et qu' il n'y a pas besoin de pas
sanitaires pour y parvenir il pourrait
pas revenir fort de la conviction que le
vaccin aille aux gens et non pas obliger
les gens à coups de menaces de
licenciement de perte de salaire
de répression de toutes sortes à aller
au vaccin la faute c'est gouvernement
qui depuis le début a menti et ré
changer de position pris du retard tout
ça crée un vaste soupçon une paston
crâne dans le pays et ses manifestations
correspondent à cela mais je voudrais
dire tout de suite car il leur manque
quelque chose si je peux me permettre
pourquoi n'y at il pas un moteur complet
licenciement pourquoi n'y at il pas un
moddeur complet mises à pied pourquoi
n'y at il pas des mots d'ordre pour la
le fait que contre les profiteurs de la
pandémie contre pour le brevet gratuit
pour la pandémie pourquoi n'y at-il pas
la protection de la médecine du travail
je l'entends pas pareille bêtise du
travail alors que pour 18 millions et
demi salariés du privé par exemple c'est
décisif et la médecine et travail
implique secret médical et secret
médical implique que s'il y avait des
discussions entre le salarié et le
médecin eh ben on voit s'il est apte ou
pas apte et ça permet de discuter de la
concrétisation ou pas du vaccin et des
objections qu'ils ont fait la médecine
du travail c'est très important ce
serait le moment de la reconstruire
de la même façon pour ce qu'on appelait
les comités hygiène sécurité et
conditions de travail ils sont disparus
on voit le drame
le drame que représente les lois y
compris les lois pays co qui ont cassé
le code du travail parce que s'il y
avait ces instruments de concertation et
de discussion les entreprises beaucoup
ne se à quoi nous assistons n'aurait pas
lieu de la même façon il y avait des
délégués du personnel vous savez que son
code du travail depuis la casse en
parlant des macros et ben on est passé
de 425 mille délégués du personnel à ce
200 milles alors il ya plus
d'interlocuteur il ya plus d'élus pour
parler en confiance entre le salarié et
le patron et le médecin est donc tout
sacré je vois j'écoute les gens qui
disent liberté liberté mais une liberté
bien sûr mais c'est liberté de ne pas se
faire licencier ses libertés de se faire
écouter l'entreprise ces libertés
d'avoir des élus dans l'entreprise c'est
liberté de ne pas perdre de salaire
c'est liberté de ne pas être sous la
menace de l'employeur ou la menace de
contrôles policiers ou rendez compte au
début macro et madame borgne avait parlé
de 45000 euros damende
restaurateurs qui ne contrôleraient à
leurs clients tout ça est une ça montre
comment dirais-je à la fois une
incompétence une vision très
politicienne et autoritaire de la
société de la part de maquereaux et de
son gouvernement donc je souhaiterais
mois que les les manifestants jeu à
mesure du mad house près tout je suis
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
quand la primaire populaire donc je
m'adresse savent eux et je leur dit
écoutez aller le 5 octobre aussi avec le
reste des syndicats parce que ce jour là
il y aura des mots d'ordre qui vous
convienne et la liberté faut lui donner
un contenu la liberté font lui donner
une traduction sociale pour défendre la
sécurité sociale les gens qui étaient
contre le vaccin au début aux us ils
étaient pour trente pays disais ouais
julie de vivre ou de mourir
confinement égale communisme
c'est mon choix à moi et à personne
d'autre nous vivons en société bien sûr
que les choix sont collectifs alex en
bien sûr on va
tous est également vous êtes d'accord
avec gérard filoche cette crise
sanitaire à la inévitablement casser le
code du travail celui de la santé
la mise à mal nos libertés individuelles
vous pensez qu'il était inévitable de
passer par là pour y faire face
je pense pas que ce soit une atteinte
fondamentale aux libertés publiques je
pense qu'il faut garder raison le
conseil constitutionnel examine des
textes on apprend cet état qui
fonctionne on n'est pas sous dictature
chinoise ou nord-coréenne je pense que
voilà il faut quand même qu'on conserve
garder raison après je partage peut-être
un ensemble de choses jusque là pu dire
mon interlocuteur peut être
effectivement un début très difficile de
la vaccination c'est vrai qu'il reste 1
et forme je pense non pas forcément au
monde du travail mais au plus 80 ans où
effectivement la médecine de ville doit
davantage se déployer je pense
effectivement aussi au quartier
populaire où je pense qu'il faut que on
a davantage encore au bas des immeubles
dont on voit bien moi je suis président
d'un conseil départemental on voit bien
sûr les collèges les secteurs on a et
selon les catégories
socioprofessionnelles on a des taux de
vaccinations qui sont différents après
je crois que c'est aussi notre
responsabilité est là je suis plus
critique de dire que ce week-end dans un
pays progrès nous sommes une pasteure
sur le pays de la science je pense pas
qu'on puisse en des vaccins français oui
mais néanmoins je pense que on a tous
reçu une éducation
de haut niveau éducation scientifique et
je pense que notamment les élus ou les
leaders d'opinion se doivent de faire la
promotion du vaccin et je pense qu'il
faut sortir des ambiguïtés puisque on
voit que les ambiguïtés on les paie en
termes de morts on le voit dans certains
régions ultramarines ou des élus sont
pas très claires manque de courage on le
voit aussi dans le sud de la france je
pense qu'il ya certains propos où on
envoie
actuellement les gens en corbillard et
je pense que faire très attention à ce
qu'on dit je suis aussi attachés aux
libertés publiques j'ai pas le sentiment
d'être un élu qui promet encore une fois
la corée du nord ou la chine pour autant
on est happé liberté je pense qu'il faut
dédramatiser tout ça il ya un examen du
conseil constitutionnel ait un équilibre
qui a été trouvé avec le sénat je
partage l'idée que le texte le texte du
gouvernement qui était passé en conseil
des ministres à mon avis monté trop haut
dans les tours
mais bon il a fait l'objet d'un sombre
de correctifs on va avoir un nouveau
rendez vous pour voir si on prône on
prolonge veut pas sanitaire je pense
qu'il sera aussi l'occasion peut-être de
l'aménager je pense par exemple les
grandes surfaces c'est totalement
inutile par contre dans les restaurants
je le trouve que effectivement mais je
suis pas forcément rassuré quand je dans
un restaurant de savoir que quelqu'un
est pas vaccinés à deux mètres de moi je
suis désolé c'est aussi c'est pas une
avalanche si c'est pas une atteinte à la
liberté d'empêcher un citoyen français
qui n'est ni vaccinés qui ne possède
annie de test négatif
d'aller au restaurant au cinéma c'est
pas une atteinte à la liberté
de travailler en tout cas
d'empêcher un soignant de le mettre à
pied parce qu'il n'est pas vacciné
l'empêcher de travailler c'est pas une
atteinte les questions des libertés
c'est toujours la conciliation le droit
à la santé c'est mon droit de vivre est
aussi une de mes libertés publiques de
l'ue libertés fondamentales et je suis
désolé si quelqu'un
par un comportement par une nouvelle
assignation ne met en péril me met en
danger ma vie ben oui j'ai le droit de
souhaiter qu'un gouvernement un moment
qu un centre de régulation qui sont pas
fondamentales on a la chance d'avoir un
vaccin on met gratuitement à disposition
de tous nos concitoyens dans d'autres
pays du monde c'est inaccessible
profitons-en profitons-en franchement on
peut on peut s'en sortir on risque cet
hiver il ya des risques parce que vous
savez quand on vit davantage fermé ça
être le cas de l'hiver il ya un risque
potentiel que une probation plus forte
du virus moi j'ai pas envie de refaire
de fermer j'ai envie justement d'aller
au stade j'ai envie d'aller au
restaurant mais j'ai envie de le faire
de manière la plus sécurisante possible
et d'être avec des gens qui sont
vaccinées parce que je n'ai pas envie
d'attraper cette maladie je suis papa
fumeur je vais dans une école
régulièrement j'ai pas envie de
transmettre aux enfants je vais voir mes
parents j'ai un papa 82 ans j'ai pas
envie de lui transmettre la maladie donc
voilà la liberté d'aller et venir très
bien mais il ya aussi la contrepartie
c'est la liberté des autres est la
contrepartie de la liberté c'est de la
responsabilité
gérard filoche en à une journée
interprofessionnelle
de manifestations qui va s'annoncer pour
le 5 octobre plusieurs professions sont
appelés à faire grève et à défiler dans
les rues contre la vaccination
obligatoire notamment contrôle pas
sanitaires vous pensez que cette
participation si elle est plus ou moins
importante elle peut faire
un peu encouragé le gouvernement à faire
marche arrière ce que le gouvernement
peut revenir par exemple sur
l'obligation vaccinale pour certains
corps de métier je pense notamment aux
soignants aux gendarmes ou encore aux
pompiers
moi je crois que il faut aller eux au 5
octobre tous ceux qui manifestent
aujourd'hui et depuis deux mois vous
avalez à mon avis au 5 octobre avec les
organisations syndicales ça va se
traduire à juste titre par des
revendications concrètes parce que d'où
vient toute cette méfiance et toute
cette confusion
avec macron j'entends monsieur il met
pas en cause le gouvernement il le
couvre mais avec mâcon en fait au début
il n'y avait pas de gel et avait pas de
masse qui avait pas serein n'y avait pas
respirateur il n'y avait pas de ligne
avait pas soignants y avait pas d
guillon y avait pas de tout serein il
n'y avait pas de blouse et par exemple
dans les territoires ultra marins dont
monsieur a parlé bah c'est ça qui
manquait le plus c'est la méfiance est
grande vous avez d'un gouvernement qui
vous fait pas de vaccin non plus qui
retarde piqué après fait un forcing et
il ya une méfiance grande depuis 20 voix
sur la façon dont ce grand accroissement
gérer cette crise et donc toutes les
contestations qu'elle nous assistons
sont la fougasse traduisent en
revendication positive positif sur la
protection de l'emploi des soignants
positive son recrutement de plusieurs
centaines de milliers de soignants
positif sur le fait qu'on n'ouvre délit
parce que depuis 18 mois macron à et
veyran ont fermé et line on avance le
chiffre de 10 800 lits en moins depuis
18 mois et et le budget losc est
annoncée pour les hôpitaux pour l'année
prochaine et un budget presque autant ou
sinon plus aux stériles terre que ce
qu'il était en 2009 faut souligner que
pendant 2019 pendant un an tous les
soignants in et enfin on n'a pas les
moyens le soir tout va mal l'hôpital est
au bord de la crise de nerfs sos cours
il va y avoir des morts et macro n'a
rien entendu et donc c'est ça qui se
soldent aujourd'hui le 5 octobre nous
entendons mettre en cause à la fois la
politique de macron et revendiquer des
effectifs des salaires la garantie d'un
emploi dans de meilleures conditions
pour tous les soignants et il en manque
il en manque il en manque et si on les
rassurer qu'ils soient mieux payés vous
savez c'est comme on dit qu'il ya des
emplois aujourd'hui n'ont plus revu je
ne vois pas vraiment mais on dit les
gens veulent pas revenir dans la
restauration mais il ya qu à les payer
et donc vous serez est ample et si on
les paye le et la société ira mieux
parce que la question des salaires est
une question cruciale est donc là va
être posée le 5 octobre on va dire qu'il
faut augmenter les salaires on va dire
qu'il faut un smic à 1600 euros on va
dire qu'il faut 300 euros de plus pour
tout le monde et que cette
redistribution des richesses est aussi
une issue parce que qu'est-ce qu'ils
sont pas aussi des excuses au sol
excusez moi je termine ya une fracture
sociale et rim fracture sociale est un
facteur culturel une fracture
géographique et une fracture économique
il faut la réduire alors maintenant
on va écouter a également alexandre tous
vous êtes d'accord avec gérard filoche
sur cette
méfiance défiance d'une partie de la
population française à l'égard notamment
de la parole gouvernementale et ce début
de gestion un petit peu maladroit de la
part du gouvernement
écoutez dire que ça a été extraordinaire
je veux pas dire ça et je pense que même
le reconnaît ce qui est un somme
d'erreurs sur les masques de leurs
erreurs qui porte sur plusieurs
gouvernements je pense que personne
n'utilise entre
d'autocritique sur le sujet je pense que
le lancement de la campagne de
vaccination n'était pas non plus très
terrible je pense qu'effectivement de
temps en temps une communication qui
auraient davantage associés je pense
effectivement le monde du travail sur
les syndicats que ce soit les syndicats
patronaux salariés que ce soit les
collectivités locales je pense qu'on
aurait pu aller beaucoup plus loin dans
les partenariats et beaucoup plus
mobilisés
collectivités quelque chose de beaucoup
un descendant après bon je partage pas
mais s'arrêtera pas avec gérard filoche
l'objectif de lutte des classes chacun
ses idées politiques mais je pense que
il ya effectivement par ailleurs on sort
d'une période de plus de 18 mois qui ont
été une base légale extrêmement
éprouvante pour chacun et on le voit
bien
il ya effectivement des conflits sociaux
dont on voit bien qu'il ya d'énervement
dans la société
qui a un problème effectivement même de
santé mentale on voit bien que tout le
monde est énervé qui a un niveau
d'acidité dans notre pays qui est assez
inégal et c'est pour ça que je pense que
à titre personnel je ne fuis pas je suis
pas à ma chronique mais j'essaye de
garder mon sang froid et je pense que en
tant qu'élu local ou à mon devoir c'est
peut-être d'apaiser les choses
après chacun voilà va revendiquer la
manifester c'est bien naturel moi je me
suis fut plutôt d'essayer de trouver des
solutions plutôt d'apaiser et puis re à
un vote dans quelques mois il y aura une
confrontation des voix là et je pense
que c'est dans ce cadre là c'est dans ce
cadre démocratique chacun pourra
s'exprimer de façon
jade irrespectueuse des idées du débat
sans forcément voilà se jeter dans les
barricades mais on pourra faire des
prêts choix et pour moi vous savez les
les choix démocratiques il s'effectue
pas dans la rue où s'effectuent dans
leur dos chaque français vaut chaque
français chaque voix vaut chaque fois et
c'est ça la vie publique
super esprit dans ce département je vais
devant les élections je vais devant mes
concitoyens je pense que c'est plus une
épreuve de vérité fort ce manque de lait
manifestera le mossad fin alexandre
touzet merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes vice
président et les républicains du
département de l'essonne merci à vous
également gérard filoche porte parole de
la gauche démocratique et sociale bonne
pelouse